buenas tardes
bienvenidos les voy a pedir que todos
pensemos en algún lugar que nos haga
sentir especiales
un lugar de esos que nosotros en el
momento que entramos nos empieza a
sentir tenemos que tenemos una conexión
con ellos
que nos cambia desde los ojos nos cambia
la médula nos cambia el latido para
algunos puede ser un paseo por la
naturaleza otros entrar a una iglesia
para algunos otros puede ser la casa de
la familia un restaurante cualquier
lugar en especial para mí son este tipo
de lugares
y van a decir si los doctores eficientes
soy doctor médico están un poquito locos
desde el momento en que yo entro a este
tipo de lugares
empieza el prat en una transformación
interna en el sentido de que yo paso por
ese tipo de pasillos y empiezo a verlo
con óptica diferente porque nosotros lo
vemos con óptica de que son lugares de
sufrimiento son lugares tristes pero yo
lo veo como otro de otro sentido luego
como lugares de oportunidades me gusta
ver qué equipamiento está muy sensible
esto qué equipamiento tienen en estas
salas y el por qué lo tienen y lo veo
con óptica diferente luego con una
óptica de oportunidades y de crecimiento
y de muchas gentes que están
involucradas aquí porque aquí no se hace
la labor del médico aquí desde la labor
de ingenieros la labor de arquitectos la
labor de psicólogos la labor de todas
las personas que hacen que esto llegue a
ser posible
son lugares tan especiales que cambios
tan pequeños tan pensados y tan precisos
tienen un impacto en algo tan importante
que es la salud como puede ser algo tan
pequeño como la iluminación en un cierto
espacio
entonces vemos estos grandes lugares los
grandes lugares que nos llegan a cambiar
y que nos generan ciertas emociones y
decimos ok para ti son los hospitales
para mí son lugares independientes para
mí son los parques para mí son los
museos para mí son los restaurantes para
mí son otros espacios y tú dices cómo
puedo ser yo parte de uno de estos
espacios cómo puedo yo ser parte como
colaborar cómo puedo crear y para hacer
estos dos lugares estos lugares tan
especiales hay que primero vivir la
experiencia hay que vivirlos hay que
conocerlos y ya que los conoces ahora
decís es ya soy un completo apasionado
como conoce a jugar fútbol no sabes qué
es el fútbol hasta que puedas el fútbol
y ya te crece tu pasión por el fútbol
así me creció la pasión por los
hospitales no es el momento que yo nací
fue después poco a poco se fue generando
esta pasión por estos lugares y un lugar
como éste se forma con dos tipos de
personas
con líderes y con colaboradores y
siempre tenemos la imagen de que el
líder es la persona que lo hace y la
persona que tiene que desarrollarlo y el
que jalar la carreta para que todo se
haga una realidad pero no es cierto los
colaboradores son tan importantes como
el líder y hay que romper ese paradigma
entonces porque pongo esta imagen porque
para mí es un ejemplo de un líder un
médico que entendió lo que le pedí el
mercado entendió que el mercado le
estaba pidiendo un hospital privado
rodeado de hospitales públicos de alta
especialidad y este médico supo que solo
no lo podía hacer que necesitaba de un
grupo de colaboradores que necesitaba
arquitectos que necesitaba ingenieros
que necesitaba contadores que
necesitaban mercadólogos que necesitaba
chefs que necesitaba una serie de cosas
y eso a través de los años y a través de
los esfuerzos a través de grandes
colaboradores se logran estas grandes
instituciones instituciones que en
personas como yo generan un gran
sentimiento diferente instrucciones bien
pensadas porque no nada más piensan en
la salud piensan en que la gente
y también tienen que comer porque los
restaurantes en los hospitales y la
comida en general es bastante mala y
ellos logran hacerlo bastante bien
poniendo restaurantes de altísima
calidad se preocupa componer un hotel
adentro de un hospital para que para que
la gente que venga de fuera no tenga que
trasladarse incluso puede atenderse en
el mismo día y quedarse no en las
habitaciones hospitalarias sino quedarse
en un hotel con facilidades más cómodas
entonces
vamos un poquito
no se quite entonces vamos un poquito
más allá cuando es cuando nosotros
debemos empezar a crear estas sinergias
estas colaboraciones y yo les diría
desde el momento en que iniciamos
nuestra vida profesional y aquí estamos
parados en un lugar donde muchas veces
empezamos nuestra vida profesional y
nuestra vida profesional puede empezar
antes de la carrera puede empezar
durante la carrera o en el caso de los
médicos
empieza muchos años después de haber
terminado la carrera entonces cuando es
cuando debo de empezar nosotros en el
momento en que entramos a la carrera
entramos y nos empezamos a separar
primero nos separamos los leyes se ponen
traje y les gusta que les digan
licenciados desde el día uno los de
medicina los ponemos de blanco y los
identificamos en un edificio porque
ellos son un poquito raros y están un
poquito locos y los mandamos
completamente aislados los de
comunicación arquitectura y diseño
generalmente tienen el edificio más
bonito y son las personas más relajadas
y las personas más cool
de la universidad pero qué pasa nosotros
no hablamos entre todos nosotros no
colaboramos porque cada quien está en su
línea de trabajo y en su línea de
materias y si tenemos algunas materias
de tronco común sobre todo de
humanidades donde tenemos cierta
interacción pero qué pasaría si nosotros
una vez al semestre dos veces a semestre
tres al semestre incluso al final de la
carrera nos plantearán y nos pusiéramos
a resolver un problema en específico que
juntaron a personas de diferentes
semestres y diferentes carreras a ver
cómo resolver el problema de un
restaurantero cómo resolver el problema
de un director general y qué opinará el
psicólogo la psicóloga qué opinará el
doctor la doctora qué opinarán el
ingeniero qué opinarán diferentes
profesiones y que todos tenemos una
opinión desde ese momento nosotros
aprenderemos a escuchar y ver que el
líder no es el dueño de todas las
opiniones o el dueño de todo el
seguimiento el curso que se va a hacer
nosotros aprendemos de los líderes que
pueden ser los que ponen la semilla pero
todos los colaboradores y todas
personas y todas las opiniones tienen un
peso y tienen un valor y hay que
aprender a escucharlas entonces seguimos
en la carrera y qué pasaría si nuestra
tesis final no fuera únicamente
comprobar una hipótesis sino realmente
hacer un planteamiento donde
involucramos cuatro o más carreras para
resolver un problema real que tengamos
en nuestro estado en nuestro país en
cualquier momento en cualquier lugar
puede ser un problema de emprendimiento
puede ser un problema de salud puede ser
un problema del área donde ustedes digan
yo en la vida profesional justamente mi
primer trabajo fueron las clínicas de
hemodiálisis unas clínicas de
hemodiálisis que el dueño no era un
nuevo médico era un ingeniero y este
ingeniero me decía a mi doctor me decía
hay que hacer la atención accesible
efectiva y digna y hay que ver la
atención sanitaria como procesos y yo le
decía pero no tenemos manuales y tenemos
normas me dice si los manuales y las
normas nos siguen para tener
cumplimientos pero analice el proceso y
los ingenieros con una visión de cadena
de suministros me enseñaron a analizar
el proceso ya ver que cada proceso de la
enfermedad y cada proceso del
tratamiento puede llegar a ser mejorable
entonces un ingeniero me da un gran
aprendizaje y después por el caminar de
la vida empieza a tener otro tipo de
mentores otro tipo de mentores que me
llegan a enseñar que muchas veces si
nosotros cuando somos chicos cuando
somos antes entabla licenciatura y a mí
me dijeran
y tú quieres hacer un hospital yo diría
así fácil junto a mis cuatro y si hago
un hospital a la mitad de la carrera me
dicen andrés quiero hacer un hospital y
yo digo no fíjate sea complicado porque
los equipos que están a lana y está
bastante complicado la situación ahorita
al terminar de la carrera me lo plantean
y digo imposible está completamente
difícil entonces nuestra capacidad
creativa y nuestras ganas de hacer los
sueños y de crecer los límites poco a
poco cuando nos vamos nos vamos
limitando y una persona completamente
ajena a la medicina un contador me
enseña con un ejemplo de cómo si se
puede hacer que no le tengas miedo a
equivocarte porque el que tiene miedo a
equivocarse y el que tiene miedo a
cometer errores es alguien que no va a
hacer nada en la vida no tengas miedo de
equivocarte
y a todo lo que hagas ponle todo el
corazón cuando realmente te hago que
salgo dedica toda tu energía ponle todo
tu corazón pero permea esta energía
hacia todos tus colaboradores que todos
entiendan lo que estás haciendo que
todos entiendan que el contador entienda
por qué es importante llevar esta
contabilidad el uso eficiente de los
recursos que el mercadólogo entiende el
mensaje que están tratando de transmitir
que cada una de las partes se siente
involucrada y que cada una de las partes
se ponga realmente la camiseta y seamos
colaboradores o seamos líderes vamos a
hacer parte de sueños increíbles
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]